ross we're going to kick off the news
with the biggest headline there is today
please tell us what happened okay this
is so bizarre you guys all right so um
i'm going to tell you something that
like nobody knows all right about a year
ago i met somebody who just changed my
life totally and his name is dr
wellington garcia and he is an educator
and he's a hilarious and he's the
smartest person i ever met and um
you know beyonce
says
if you like it then you should have put
a ring on it mm-hmm well
i did okay
[Applause]
i can't even believe it but yes i am the
happiest man i met somebody so extreme
there we are look there we are
and um
i know look at him oh ross i'm so happy
and you guys
met in this last year which to me is
such an amazing sign for people we
started dating right before the pandemic
and then we had to date through
quarantine you know making those those
zoom dates and uh and then eventually
traveling and being together and and
making it work cheers to you
[Applause]
found the cheers name ever by the way
i'm the best man ever and i'm just so
happy and i i've been so private about
this relationship and it feels so weird
because i tell you guys everything on my
podcast and here on this show so i'm so
happy to be sharing this with um with
all of you and thank you drew well that
is the best news we're gonna get in a
long time let alone today and we're just
floating on cloud nine
right along with you rossi and we're
gonna keep the romance going with our
first story because we've got some early
scoop on guess what ross oh i know say
it bridger
obsessed deadline reports that actress
simone ashley has been cast as the love
interest for anthony bridgerton played
by jonathan bailey now we all know the
new season is going to focus around
their love affair he is as good as it
gets he is riveting and i think that she
is just beautiful extraordinary and i
want to say
that this is the power of casting when
people take casting risks and they
discover someone it's a very big deal
and i really thank the show for doing
that with simone i'm very excited to see
her well they did it in season one i
wasn't aware of these actors before and
now i'm obsessed with all of them and
i'm obsessed with her already i've been
pouring through her images she almost
looks different in each photo but she is
stunning
[Music]
you